on a gagné il faut deux points d'écart
non pas ici
il est centré des profs de yoga dans le
gymnase maintenant
la balle et je viens de remarquer que tu
pousses pas assez sur tes jambes quand
tu sautes tes déshydraté 100 dollars que
tu mets moins de paniquement à 300 c'est
d'accord je suis pas un fils à papa moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas comme ça que les Noirs
obtiendront réparation pour le paiement
je préférais un virement avec ton tel
mais t'en fais pas si tu préfères le
cash
je comprends pas à quoi tu joues tu
débarques habillé comme IP tu fais celui
qui sait pas jouer à cru que je savais
pas jouer parce que je suis blanc et ça
c'est complètement con et rétrograde
j'ai pensé ça parce que tu te balades
avec des testicules autour du cou
j'essaie de planifier notre avenir
ensemble de façon réaliste parce que tu
continues de te bercer dilution c'est ma
cure détox vous voulez un petit
échantillon non je suis pas intoxication
on est bientôt le premier dimanche
il y a 25000 dollars pour le vainqueur
faut juste que je trouve quelqu'un pour
jouer avec moi et empocher le pognon tu
te fous de moi 25000 dollars pour les
vainqueurs pour une journée
c'est le week-end prochain mais avant
faut trouver l'argent pour payer
l'inscription je vais repérer des cibles
ce petit short rouge il va ravir les
déstabiliser tu fais du porno et le tour
sera joué tu vas garder ton sac poubelle
et toi tu gardes ta tenue de vieux
épices fatigué là
vous devez avoir des points communs qui
ne sautent pas aux yeux voilà s'il te
plaît
et le pour moi
les frais d'accord toi dépense pas tout
je sais j'ai un budget comme moi je gère
moi aussi parfait parfait parfait alors
je suis ravie
[Musique]
j'ai pas l'impressionnant quoi
on est où là dans Mad Max
je sais pas si ton petit discours y est
pour quelque chose mais c'était du bon
boulot merci toi tu pourrais baratiner
qui tu veux il y a tellement de sujets
que j'ai pas le droit d'aborder
comme quoi
laisse tomber non mais je t'écoute
[Musique]